f murray abraham is here we're live so
you can come join us Ruby welcome - Sam
how are you welcome to the show thank
you yes well thank you for being here
very exciting times homeland the whole
thing right amazingly with these these
shows where you interview so many people
because I know how you get it all
straight I'm yeah keep it all in time
anybody have notes we do have noticed
but we also screw up a lot yeah so
you're allowed at Murray Abraham is here
to promote the office a great airline a
select oh yeah I don't know you kind of
know you kind of just have to pack your
weight affects sitting for like a test
in school like I tend to pack my brain
full of stuff the night before for this
show and then by tomorrow I want to talk
it's gone it's really over it yeah I
believe that yeah yeah well I mean I got
to imagine like like when you've got a
role and you've got a memorized dialogue
or seems like you're not memorizing a
movie you're going right do you mean by
seeing as soon as you're finished
shooting it then the brain relaxes right
exactly like you're just in that space
and I've worked with a lot of actors
whose brains are awful it's relaxed is
that right it's wait what guys were lazy
and don't want to learn what they're
supposed to learn the better they're
stoned out of their minds
oh are you patient on set if that
happens like are these disguise an
[ __ ] can you do no I never used
language like this Tom me neither
normally where you can oh yeah yeah it's
gonna be cool this is radio right right
I can pick my nose
you can we you want to that's the other
family that goes it by you we don't need
to do a lot of prep because we can curse
and talk about eating the grass we can
have a Hollywood legend in C you know
make jokes about eating boogers within
two minutes so it's really not a problem
for her I'm so good I'm here really we
miss each other
III we'd never we've never met but you
were at the Louis CK's house one oh
thank you yeah and I came and I was so
bummed that you had already left that
was a really if you had him on the show
we've all yet for years yeah yeah we I
was I'm destroyed in every man he really
is you played his father was right I
played his uncle or his uncle okay
and did you ever see that segment I can
yes we shot it in the Russian Tea Room
but the fact is that he exists some
months months later somebody stopped me
on the street who was a relative of
Louis and he said that's him
that's what the guys really really like
that amazing character anyway it was a
treat these are good he's a good man to
work for by the way you enjoy nice to be
able to say that about someone actually
I mean is not a jerk he's right he's
really terrific Wow
yeah is it one of those scenarios we
almost wish like like let's just do more
projects oh wait wouldn't do more let's
figure out what else we can do what I
keep seeing by to be back I've done
three different characters on the show
right so I'm not looking for more work
it would always be nice yeah but did you
see that thing he did that the short
series he made hard often yes is that
fantastic yeah I also like that he's
doing stuff that's not so like by the
book like he's not doing stuff tonight
into a genre or to an audience he's
doing the shows he wants an original mom
yes but we're here to talk about me
absolutely I was all using him to segue
back into I didn't like we went off on
him at all okay and you I was fascinated
to know you used to go into Juarez
because I'm kind of fascinated with
Juarez is it such a scary place and
there's so much cartel violence and
growing up in Texas you guys would go
down there and when you were a kid yeah
I was never that dangerous though it
wasn't bad then I grew up two blocks
from the Rio Grande and people coming
back and forth across the river new to
work you know there was nowhere any
danger he some practical lived in Juarez
would you do there are none of your
business
oh come on Tommy it's by the same stuff
I do here I don't know how we got away
with it but the hookers were $2 from
dollar and a half a piece and we were
introduced to sex that way
Wow and that's just what kids did in the
guy who sold us savea's way too pricy
I'm fascinated yes you know what bugger
your apartment you see all my God all my
CDs and I can own the building if I was
getting together yeah that's the way a
lot of guys get introduced to it myself
included in a lot of ways and it's weird
reason reason is because you said we're
lucky we had none of us got any diseases
so I think back then you just didn't
think of a guy should know the dick
doesn't have a conscience this is the
way we're going to go it says there you
go that way right so we was lucky it was
but but we could eat cheap Revere we
could we can't afford to live like like
like young men on very little money and
how old are you and they start Oh God
ten no no probably run must've been
about 14 some few 14 when you'll ask you
in generally that's pretty amazing
yeah 13 14 that's not unusual I don't
know if it's that unusual now I don't
know I mean I'd like to think it is
because it was way after that for me but
that's probably just me yeah so do you'd
go down there and use that for a couple
of years you guys would go down and
wallow you should be the place to go
because you could afford it from one
thing it was cheap and it was good and
looking good
you could behave like like an adult at
14 or 15 right tequila was 10 cents a
shot for example did you have like a red
star using like a regular place you'd go
Chile okay yeah Rafa we like yeah it was
a parise de noche I remember exactly
berries they don't [ __ ] that's right and
the place we hung out was friends it was
a it was a bar 10 bucks in cents a shot
of whiskey have you been back at all
digits look you know this was every time
that's funny because every time I speak
Spanish I grew up speaking Spanish and
then and and laura's and Mexicans were
part of my life I've always believed I'm
a Mexican soul frankly and the idea that
when I go back there to visit they say
oh you don't go where's now it's too
much trouble it really is a
heartbreaking because it was part of my
life it was a good part
it's not all this we're talking about
just drinking in [ __ ] that's excellent
it was a culture of people that I
responded to and identified with it was
the courtesy about Mexican people and
you may have get away with it though
because even the cartel guys whenever
they get them they all have Scarface
posters like these for real hi there
worship Tony Montana you may be one of
the few guys you Pacino who could
actually probably go through there
safely if they realized who you were in
function huh yeah out of respect for the
film
yeah I guess maybe you're right get hurt
when they threw you out of the
helicopter terrible question yes were
you afraid to fly at that point the guy
who got thrown out I don't if you know
but these stunt men and women negotiate
each stunt because each ton is different
I didn't know if I saw their salary
honorees I'm not saying right from them
yeah and this guy who did that stunt out
of the helicopter
never done that before he said you
better have several cameras set up cuz
I'm gonna do this one time and if you
look carefully you'll see this chute
come off his foot and come up through
the frame really yeah
it was a scary thing but when I did it
it was a shot from down you want to hear
this
hey yeah I was found that the camera was
down but I guess about three or four
feet below this of this mound of this
side of this cliff and the helicopter
was there and what they had done we set
up a whole bunch of cardboard boxes
that's what these guys jump out onto and
it's okay when we when we push out of
the helicopter here's how the noose
works they showed me the rope and said
here it is it's not really connected so
that if anything goes wrong it'll pop
loose and you won't be strangled and I
said let's shoot this let's not rehearse
it because it's never going to be as
scary as it is the first time right I
gotta tell you something man you put
that rope around your neck even though
you know it's [ __ ] scared and you got
pushed out and I got pushed out and I
went you know three or four feet then
the next time I said whoo that's good
again right right that's the difference
yeah there is that thing where it's like
even if they tell you it's going to be
okay sure the first time right once you
once you actually go through it and it's
okay exactly that's when you know it's
like I'm nine I got nothing to worry
about
if you want to try and experiment along
those lines if you know someone with a
pistol make sure that it's empty and put
in your mouth and see what happens I've
done similar things your business the
pistol of the gym puts in his mouth are
usually loaded thank you and more
dangerous in the guns
so this slow killer you guys get painful
it we don't and and you're promoting a
homeland and yeah amazing what people
there's a whole big thing like all him
and Manny Potemkin don't get along and
then you feel like that that's not true
and it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] right
but it's similar to kiss it's good for
business
yeah people say it gets people talking
about homeland there's known each other
for forty years
nonsense have you gotten to the point
where when when on set rumors like that
or around do you just blow them off me
like its promotion for the show I do but
you know it doesn't happen that often
with me but these really prominent
actors all that [ __ ] that people write
about them I don't know they blow it all
you know how do they keep from getting
crazy right your prominent actor well
want me Oscar
I'm prominent I don't know you one the
interesting thing yeah that's nice but
the where do you have a think about but
you know right I turned to you know name
sure a really good famous actor I mean I
did I'm I did a play once with a couple
of very famous people hmm but I did
Waiting for Godot who was in that shame
on me Steve Martin steam arm with a
Robin Williams yeah and we tried to walk
from the rehearsal to lunch we never did
that again because they come out of the
woodwork for these guys and it is that
guy now that's prominent actor that's
fame well you know you have they're also
grabbing you man it looks like like
segment it's scary
they were grabbing them I mean really
pulling them take a picture with me come
on a Stevie I like you a [ __ ] off
another a very petite I said his last
name wrong so stinky Potemkin Cadillac I
kind of like you a perfect battleship
yeah I said this thing does that make
you grateful for like your position
you're like you know what I have an
Oscar I don't need the level of fame
that a Steve Martin and Robin Williams
have if that's what comes with it well
that's true but you also don't have the
money that comes with every night doing
it look like my life is really in the
theater when you when you when you want
it obviously we asked everybody can't
kind of a similar question like what are
you thinking right before they Regent
there's no way I'm getting this or you
kind of know like I'm confident oh it's
that thing you're happens like you're
going out on the day
is it going to work tonight right you
know and your sofa best try to pretend
like it doesn't matter and of course it
matters like crazy right it's not just
an honor to be on the date like the
honor is to seal the deal at the end of
a story they want to go home
people talk about being cool like I know
I mean it looked cool but I was you
inside yeah I wanna go I wanna yeah so
you win it and then you go home and it's
get that whole party that nice got to be
the most amazing thing to do that you're
the man of the hour
does that wear off in a day or two or I
can ask when is the high where all when
is a high yeah yeah immediately that's
it yeah because what you do is you go
from that which Hollywood really does
well ya know and you go that to your
life you know which is back in Brooklyn
right my family you know and breakfast
getting the kids to school right and you
think well I like the other one too yeah
you know I know I'm starting I'm here
with it all right is there a party
tonight thank you exactly it was just
the one in LA and then you got on a
plane but it was possible if I had
stayed there
mmm because I went back to Brooklyn the
next day it would have continued because
they five on that yes you know and it
was a question of doing that and
promoting myself and you know the future
and I said no I go home oh you are wrong
yeah just you wish you hadn't for a few
days
I want to do I wanted to share my Oscar
with my neighbors yeah you have your our
um my mother is attacking lady and I'm a
real Italian son I gotta tell you and
she had a god rest her soul she had it
there on the mantelpiece
with two candles she was so proud oh
you're Italian I am in my father Syrian
he was a Syrian refugee in the last
century he wants there's a bother us
going on now in there they're going to
be denied entry being afraid of the
three or forty five-year-old Syrian
orphan children doesn't seem American to
me be nice to open the doors of at least
of it to the orphans anyhow yeah and you
wonder to like they were like wow
I mean when they're kids they're going
to be conditioned to be terrorists as
they grow older and you're like if
anything's going to condition a four or
five-year-old to be a terrorist wouldn't
it be not to bring them finding out when
when as they get older you mean I could
have gone to America four or five and
they wouldn't let me in yeah my my
family was super Patriots because of
them I mean they saved their lives they
came over here starving because it was
it was a famine in Syria and in those
days and the point is that my two
brothers are in a military cemetery I
mean your Patriots I'm a spokesperson
for the multi faith Alliance for Syrian
refugees have you gone back a lot too
it's hard to go back these days mutation
a bit dangerous sure sure but I mean
they're gonna go back anywhere you can't
go back to Syria I can't go back to
Juarez like you just left a trail of
damage everywhere yeah yeah no
responsibility because but the other
thing is that I'm half-italian
yeah and Italy's pretty nice it's not
bad yeah yeah totally
no I mean but every time on you would
try to fool you had a big earthquake the
whole thing is a large get snow dumped
on the north shame yeah but it's it's I
gotta tell you you heard those good
things about Italy yeah it's all true
it's just it's so it's it's fun yeah so
yeah I've only heard good things from
people who go to Italy like they're like
they don't a lot of movies oh yeah you
have yeah I hear the food is not good
it stinks yeah it's beautiful
so you uh when did you move to Brooklyn
you guys [ __ ] crazy when you went to
Brooklyn I moved to Brooklyn when my
second child was born because he could
afford and I'm having for a little
bigger apartment and we went to Eastern
Parkway across from the museum and it
was seven big rooms for two hundred and
forty dollars real light across from
using little dicey neighborhood no Beth
I was I did so that's okay now you can
you imagine yeah baby tires nice now
they mentioned you went in pretty
awesome um you didn't buy the apartment
did you actually we did oh my god so
messy well you must have made a boatload
of money on it thank some money yeah not
like animated movies like ridiculous to
bad you couldn't kept it in just rental
right yeah
though no it was like a fraction of what
it's worth not anyway you do what you do
you do you put that's one thing you
spent time in Brooklyn when it wasn't is
nice and now it's much nicer so it's not
just everywhere it's not just this not
just Syria and Juarez like Brooklyn so
so there are there are positive ones to
our base of operations for this for
homeland is in red is in Greenpoint oh
yeah and it's the opposite right there
on the water overlooking Manhattan
spectacular yeah but there's so much
construction down there
you can't like the streets always closed
because so many buildings are going up
down there great big you know for sure I
don't we've got all the money for all
these places because you've got to know
those apartments are going to be
extravagantly expensive with that
fabulous view yeah you wonder is this
boom gonna last is the bottom going to
drop out because if Brooklyn's being
eaten up which it already has yeah
where are the young artists dancers
musician what do they live you know what
it is they move into dangerous
neighborhoods like a lot of these young
people attack hipsters or a lil anoint
but either they move into neighborhoods
that are rough and they there's always a
place that the rent is cheap and that
they find and they move into and then as
they come a coffee shop opens and then
all of a sudden more money rolls into it
but where would these area talking about
be is always this going to be the Bronx
I think it's next to scabby areas in the
bra I bet the Bronx will be next to tell
you the truth and it's so it's yeah it's
so funny like hipsters really mean well
and they're a lot of them are very open
but they have no idea like they really
are the beginning of the gentrification
right boys the beginning of the end
they don't even mean to be yeah they're
just ready for the community and then
yeah they just want to kind of live
there and pay a rent they can afford and
next thing you know it's you know
[ __ ] white people tap-dancing in
behind but they kind of laid the then
they made the path safe for us like yeah
yeah they have cleared away and they
don't mean to be they're a part of
something they're like the lead of
something that they don't agree with
right right they just try to go in and
be like yep we're just here to
experience what you guys know you're
actually taking it away yeah yeah yes
it's not intentional
so what his homeland premiere well home
runs on Sundays at 9:00 p.m. right
always it already on the season shut up
yeah compared to weeks ago yeah yeah you
know it's fine missing app is awfully
early in the morning yeah by the way
there's the answer to your question how
do you keep it all on your head you
don't know I was thinking the important
stuff like the career in Syria and wow I
wasn't thinking about the technical
stuff yeah like the stuff he's promoting
yeah the only reason he would do
interviews yeah yeah exactly I'm
concentrating on the fun stuff that's a
business at hand I apologize I see I
believe it's important to me that the
that we tell jokes because nobody tells
jokes anymore I love jokes and I've
disappeared
have you noticed yes so people are
afraid to get in try people are afraid
of getting in trouble
and because no no they're afraid because
people want to be upset to adhere to be
upset than to be funny I think
and so people home yeah and so people
decide that they want to have something
to complain about you have to be
creative to complain about writing I
know a great dumb dumb blonde joke yeah
ready
yeah hear it dumb blonde walks into a
library she says hi I like a
cheeseburger some fries and a coke
because it's maybe this is the library
she goes oh I'd like a cheeseburger
that's funny unless you're blonde and I
Samarra guys anybody climbing out I do
want to apologize sorry might be
offended and we actually take you walk
into a library but yes we people people
are just afraid to get in trouble that's
why they don't really tell jokes and
you're right it's easier to be outraged
than it is to be funny do you tackle by
the way that on Homeland like because
it's a show that deals with terrorism
and all this stuff like we don't want
certain people to be portrayed in
certain ways and and this character
needs to be portrayed by this ethnicity
because if there's too many Middle
Eastern people being shown as terrorists
and that's portraying all Middle Eastern
people is terrorists and probably like
is that anything that pops up on your
radar if the material is good I don't
think that that is part of the
conversation yeah as long as it's not
tuned on like a [ __ ] story like the
truth is the truth no matter how many
people these days think there's no such
thing as a truth ideally I think there's
a truth and I think when you see it you
recognize it you smell it yeah I don't
quite understand how people are getting
away with telling lives so
you know so freely alternative sex well
they're not lying for the [ __ ] law I
mean once I going to stop what are we
going to start calling this country the
United States of America instead of the
red states blue states right I mean it
is the United States is no yeah well
each side wants to be United because
they want the other side to just blindly
agree with them they're like wow you
know once you once you two agree
completely with me then we'll be united
so I don't know I don't I don't know why
you won't be United I think social media
and Twitter helps because everybody's
really reasonable oh you think it's very
positive that's just a good
communication tool yeah I like it I do
it even though I know it's negative in
this kind of shoes I'm shitty - it's a
good it's fun it's fine he's gotta go in
with the right headspace that you see
that expression is beautiful oh I'm I'm
shitty - wouldn't that be swell yes
yeah the fact that I put in the two is
very generous I should just I'm shutting
this area I want to include all of you
fact is I know I am know it is nice to
be able to laugh at somebody's expense
and not have it be like this whole thing
it's just a funny thing you know you
could get away with it if you would
shoot everybody down if you could insult
everyone equally well right you don't
exclude anyone but you try that but then
people always find a reason why they
shouldn't be insulted well you've never
been marginalized yeah welcome that's
exactly right
[ __ ] up against a coach oh yeah we
were we were looking at my mother got
Rossum she would beat me if she heard me
talking like this the language right yes
like that language she wouldn't let us
watch The Untouchables really he's tough
Italian I know that's not the Italians
their day other what about the dilemma
but the Jewish gangsters what about the
Irish gangster she was there this is
what I'm talking about there she didn't
like the portrayal of Italians on
television back then did you see The
Sopranos that got a lot of I wasn't
around but oh she died but I know this
what she loved the prominence of Italian
actors she was very proud of that yeah
but when I did scarf I said mama don't
watch this movie she did she said tell
out she was really serious tell al he
doesn't he shouldn't use that language
bad for the Italians I had mamas just
doing the script now now he's a star he
can do what he wants to have you guys
America five years that's right I'm not
a pretty amazing
fascinating to me yeah me too I'm
serious yeah yeah fifty-five years how
did you meet your wife just luck a guy
you know I'm leaving El Paso and without
to Elodie sick by fortune
he said look if what this girl left when
I did we've been together ever since
are you stubborn or in love I am I'll
tell you what it was a it was a G with
Robert Mitchum was asked how did he
explain the success of his long long
marriage he said lack of imagination
that interested yeah uh it's it's luck
you know if you can hang in I wish I had
advice it's just that you know you
change a difference to like it too of
you
I mean sometimes your honor really you
know on the same level same
communication level and when you're not
you pick up his hand and he's not you
pick up his it's the same thing of the
marriage you it's a little more serious
but when you get to the point and this
still happens even though I've been
together we'd be gathered all these
years or you think this woman does not
understand me
after all this [ __ ] time all these
years and at the same time she's
thinking the same thing about you right
if you get past there I mean that's the
trick right then the history that you've
gone through it's a much richer
relationship I mean regarding
relationships that you just talks off in
a year or two that's too bad but you
guys like to know you get married in 62
like you were married during the Kennedy
assassination
yeah like you like that to me that to
put a timeframe on it that fascinate yes
the couple has been together for our
time where were you guys that's an
adequate lighting are you were in LA I
was looking for my successful Wow
a long time and did you ever think like
I don't want to be in this so you're
like now this is where I want to be no
no choices dedication is my calling it
seemed late I mean I'm serious yeah
marriage there is no other option that's
why you in high school I was a double -
whoo - I was a bum yeah no gang member
in this teacher it was about 16 said you
should try this I mean nobody gave a
[ __ ] about me I was just looking to get
out of school and getting the hell out
of Belfast
what the gang did we said try the
hallways all the stupid things stealing
cars and breaking into places and you
know you go to jail yeah but it was like
that overnight
nothing yes so when you go into fights
but nobody got killed
that was just fight that's all
occasional nice no yeah but like no one
could kill unlike now Jesus these guys
are crazy that firepower yeah
now we weren't easy we're not like some
of the real big gangs no we were just
self-protection
but the point is what did how did this
woman
Lucia Hutchins my teacher and I was got
a June see through all that [ __ ] I
was going through maybe you lied once in
class or something and she's like wow
this guy's good good yeah anyway bless
her heart when you meet other actors
though especially in the beginning maybe
not so much now but in the beginning and
they're kind of some of them are like
snowflakes or whatever very delicate
right and you've kind of seen some [ __ ]
in your life already
yeah is it difficult to relate like to
people that maybe don't have the street
smarts that you acquire only from living
that kind of a life or I don't know I
just like you're judging people I don't
know yeah I did it so are you looking at
a different man than it was them right
I've been very different
that's right different around you too
though because once you win an Oscar and
you know again you were in such classic
films you're seeing a different version
of those actors and a lot of people
might see they're coming to you in a
very respectful way he's right you seem
like a very very self-aware but also
almost self like reflexive and
correcting person like you you yeah but
I'm old yeah and we're gonna have yeah
because I was reading an interview that
you did in 2013 where you were talking
about the fact that you were an [ __ ]
on Chicago Hope I think and a little bit
remembered the does show but it's
something I'm sure I was an [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah well I say yes whatever was
and and that you kind of came out of it
knowing okay I was active I was in the
wrong in that scenario and I'm not going
to be that guy yeah well that's an
interesting place to get yeah it's like
not everyone comes to those those
realizations like you said I'm an
[ __ ] too you know you continue to be
an answer will not work with them we all
have and why they don't come to some
kind of self realization unless they
just simply like being an [ __ ] we
have to go we get 10 seconds I know
after Abraham it's ah 10 P 9 p.m. on
Showtime is homeland and that's what
he's promoting yeah and we're very happy
you came in this is
make me come back yeah you're welcome to
a lot of fun we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]